Halloween's coming up is how I mean a  big deal for you yeah we're doing and  doing like a family costume probably  this year a family costume yeah okay and  then that before that's cool  now are you oh you're aware that people  your fans dress up as you and I'm  talking fans of all ages adults dress up  as Diane yeah as your character on  black-ish and we've have an example here  this is a fan who dressed up like you is  that there must be kind of flattering  and also a little weird huh it's really  cool like I'm so honored honestly yeah  yeah would you ever go out as your  character then he'll be weird yeah I was  like I don't have to do a lot shoot like  I look exactly like  [Laughter]  [Applause]  you